معالي الوزيره سيذكر تاريخ جيدا جدا ان
فرنسا عارضت بشده الحرب على العراق عام
2003 ولكنه سيذكر ايضا انها شاركت وبقوه
في حرب افغانستان في عام 2001 ما كان
الفرق في الطاعات الفرنسي بين الموضوعين
لماذا قبلت هنا ورفضت هناك
بالنسبه الى افغانستان حدث ذلك عقب احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث كانت القاعده تتخذ من
افغانستان لها وكان هناك نظام طالبان الذي
كان يقمع خصوصا النساء كذلك شاهدنا كيف
دمر طالبان التماثيل الكبرى في افغانستان
التي تنتمي الى التراث العالمي المشترك
وحقوق الانسان كانت منتهكه في افغانستان
وكانه محرومات من حق التعليم وبما انه تم
استهدافه الولايات المتحده مباشره من خلال
احداث الحاديه عشر من سبتمبر والمشاهد
التي شاهدناها ولا سيما منهار البرجين في
نيويورك وعليها ان تدخل فرنسا
وصديق ساعدنا في حربنا ضد النازيه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لذلك تدخلنا في
افغانستان هذا الامر تم في اطار الحلف
الاطلسي وهذا الامر لا ينبغي اغانه شاركت
في حرب افغانستان بلدان من الناتو واخرى
من خارج هذا الحلف هذا الامر مهم وتجدر
الاشاره اليه اما بالنسبه الى العراق
فالوضع مختلف كان هناك عمل وقائي بطرق غير
مقبوله بالنسبه الينا ساسرد لك طرفه لكنها
ذات مغزى في مطلع الفتره التي تسلمت فيها
وزاره الدفاع التقينا في اجتماع فبراج او
وارسو لم اعد اذكر بالضبط اين مع دونالدز
فيلد الذي كان نظير الامريكي الذي اراد
وقتها ان يقنع الاوروبيين بالمشاركه في
العمليه المنوي تنفيذها في العراق
ميسي
عدد من الصور الملتقى بواسطه الاقمار
الصناعيه وعرضها علينا حيث لم يكن هناك
الا وزراء حول الطاوله وقدمت تلك الصور
على انها من الصوت لاطلاق الصواريخ وقال
ان صدام حسين سيستخدم هذه المنصات لاطلاق
الصواريخ وكانت وصلتني اصداء عما ينوي
قوله وعرضه علينا قبل ايام من الاجتماع
فطلبت من الجيش الفرنسي انطلاقا من
اقمارنا الصناعيه التي اكبر عدد ممكن من
الصور للعراق
مضحكه
عندما عارض رامز في صوره اخرجت الصور التي
التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه الفرنسيه التي
اظهرت انها تتعلق بصوامع القمح فقدت
الزاويه التي تم من خلالها التقاط الصور
لم تكن نفسها الصور التي اظهرها
الامريكيون واعتقد كان لديهم غيرها كان
بالامكان ان تظهر وكانها من الصوت لاطلاق
الصواريخ وصور التي لدينا والماخوذه من
زاويه اخرى اظهرت انها تتعلق بمنشاه مدنيه
السياده لو لم يكن لدينا الا الصور
الامريكيه لربما كنا اعتمدنا التفسير ذاته
ولكننا لم نفعل ذلك هذا كان الموقف
الفرنسيه فنحن لم نكن نص الصف وراء
الولايات المتحده في كل ما تريده نحن نعمل
في شكل مستقل كفر يكون الامر مشروعا عندما
نشارك في عمليه عسكريه مع دوله حليفه
وصديقه تعرضت لهجوم اما في وضع اخر
لنشاركه معها عندما نجد خطا
وجكشراك ارتقى ان هناك خطا واننا سنخلق
منطقه توتر ونزاع واسعه في تلك المنطقه
اذا قمنا بتقويض العراق وكان بامكاننا
انتقاد صدام حسين ولذلك اتخذنا هذا الموقف
انا ذهبت وشرحت هذا الموقف في كل دول
الخليج وقتها كمفده من الرئيس جاك شغارك